NARRATOR: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GILBERT STRANG: OK.
So, I'd like to pick up again
on this neat family of matrices,
circulant matrices.
But first, let me say
here and then put it
on the web, my thought
about the projects.
So, I think the last deadline
I can give is the final class.
So, I think that's not
next week but Wednesday
of the following week, I think,
is our last class meeting.
So, be great to get
them then or earlier.
And if anybody or
everybody would
like to tell the class a
little bit about their project,
you know it's a
friendly audience
and I'd be happy to make
space and time for that.
So, send me an email and
give me the project earlier
if you would like to just
say a few words in class.
Or even if you are willing
to say a few words in class,
I'll say.
Yeah.
Because I realize-- yeah, OK.
So, other questions about--
so, we're finished with
all psets and so on.
So, it's really just
a project, and yeah.
STUDENT: How is
the project graded?
Like, on what basis?
GILBERT STRANG:
How is it graded?
Good question.
But it's going to
be me, I guess.
So I'll read all the projects
and come up with a grade
somehow, you know.
I hope you guys have
understood that my feeling is
that the grades
in this course are
going to be on the high
side because they should be.
Yeah.
I think it's that
kind of a course
and I've asked you to
do a fair amount, and--
anyway, that's my
starting basis.
And there's a lot of topics
like circulant matrices
that I'm not going to be able
to give you a pset about.
But of course, these
are closely connected
to the discrete
Fourier transform.
So, let me just write the
name of the great man Fourier.
So, the discrete Fourier
transform is, as you know,
a very, very important
algorithm in engineering
and in mathematics.
Everywhere.
Fourier is just
a key idea and so
I think it's just good
to know about, though.
So, circulant
matrices are connected
with finite size matrices.
Matrices of size n.
So our circulant
matrices will be N by N.
And you remember
this special form.
So, this is a key point
about these matrices,
C. That they're defined by
not n squared entries, only n.
If you tell me just the
first row of the matrix,
and that's all you would
tell Matlab, say, c0, c1, c2
to c N minus 1.
Then for a circulant,
that's all I
need to know because these
diagonals are constant.
This diagonal is constant-- c1--
and then gets completed here.
c2 diagonal come to c2 and then
gets completed cyclically here.
So, n numbers and not n squared.
The reason I mention
that, or a reason is,
that's a big selling point
when you go to applications,
say machine
learning, for images.
So, you remember the big
picture of machine learning,
deep learning, was
that you had samples.
A lot of samples, let's
say N samples, maybe.
And then each sample in this
image part will be an image.
So, the thing is that an image
is described by its pixels
and if I have 1,000
by 1,000 pixel--
so, that's a million pixels.
The feature vector,
the vector that's
associated with 1
sample, is enormous.
Is enormous.
So I have N samples but maybe--
well, if they were
in color that million
suddenly becomes 3 million.
So say 3 million features.
So, our vectors
are a vector of--
the whole computation of deep
learning works with our vectors
with 3 million components.
And that means that in the
ordinary way, if we didn't
do anything special we
would be multiplying those
by matrices of size like
3 million times 3 million.
We would be computing
that many weights.
That's like, impossible.
And we would be computing
that for each layer
in the deep network
so it would go up--
so 3 million by 3
million is just--
we can't compute.
We can't use gradient descent
to optimize that many weights.
So, the point is that the
matrices in deep learning
are special.
And they don't depend--
they're like circulant matrices.
They might not loop around.
So, circulant matrices
have this cyclic feature
that makes the theory
extremely nice.
But of course, in general we
have matrices, let's say t0--
constant diagonals and
maybe a bunch of diagonals.
And here not necessarily
symmetric, or they
might be symmetric.
But they're not cyclic.
So, what are these
matrices called?
Well, they have a bunch of names
because they're so important.
They're linear shift invariant.
Or linear time
invariant, whatever is
the right word in your context.
So, they're convolutions.
You could call it a
convolution matrix.
When you multiply by
one of these matrices,
I guess I'm going to call it t,
you're doing our convolution.
And I'll better write down
the formula for convolution.
You're not doing a
cyclic convolution
unless the matrix cycles round.
When you multiply by
C, this would give you
cyclic convolution.
Say if I multiply
C by some vector v,
the result is the
cyclic convolution
of the c vector
with the v vector.
So, big C is a matrix
but it's completely
defined by its first
row or first column.
So I just have a vector
operation in there
and it's a cyclic one.
And over here, t
times a vector v
will be the convolution of a t
vector with v, but not cyclic.
And probably these are the
ones that would actually
come into machine learning.
So, linear shift invariant,
linear time invariant.
I would call it--
so, math people would
call it a Toeplitz matrix.
That's why I used the letter t.
In engineering it would be
a filter or a convolution
or a constant diagonal matrix.
These come up in
all sorts of places
and they come up
in machine learning
and with image processing.
But basically,
because what you're
doing at one point in
an image is pretty much
what you're going to
do at the other points,
you're not going to
figure out special weights
for each little
pixel in the image.
You're going to
take-- if you have
an image, say you have an
image with zillions of pixels.
Well, you might
want to cut down.
I mean, it would be
very sensible to do
some max pooling, some pooling
operation to make it smaller.
So, that's really like, OK, we
don't want this large a system.
Let's just reduce it.
So, max pooling.
That operation would be--
say, take them 3 at a
time, some 9 pixels.
And replace that 9
pixels by 1 pixel.
So the max of those 9 numbers.
That would be a very simple
operation that just reduces
the dimension, make it smaller.
Reduce the dimension.
OK, so that's a cheap way
to make an image 4 times
or 9 times or 64 times smaller.
But the convolution part now--
so, that's not
involving convolution.
That's a different
operation here.
Not even linear if I
take the max in each box.
That's not a linear operation
but it's a fast one.
OK, so where do circulants
or convolution or Toeplitz
matrices or filters
come into it?
So, I'll forget about
the max pooling.
Suppose that's
happened and I still
have a very big system
with n squared pixels,
n squared features
for each sample.
So, I want to operate on
that by matrices, as usual.
I want to choose the weights to
bring out the important points.
So, the whole idea is--
on a image like that
I'll use a convolution.
The same operation is
happening at each point.
So, forget the max part.
Let me erase, if I can
find an eraser here.
OK, so I'm not going to--
we've done this.
So, that's done.
Now, I want to
multiply it by weights.
So, that's already done.
OK.
So, what am I looking to do?
What kind of a job
would a filter do?
A low-pass filter would
kill, or nearly kill,
the high frequencies, the noise.
So, if I wanted to get
a simpler image there,
I would use a low-pass
filter, which might just--
it might be this filter here.
Let me just put in some
numbers that would--
say 1/2 and 1/2.
So, I'm averaging each
pixel with its neighbor
just to take out some
of the high frequencies.
The low frequencies
are constant.
An all-black image would
come out not changed
but a very highly speckled
image would get largely removed
by that averaging.
So, it's the same
idea that comes up
in all of signal
processing, filtering.
So, just to complete
this thought of,
why do neural nets-- so,
I'm answering this question.
How do they come in
machine learning?
So, they come when
the samples are images
and then it's natural to use
a constant diagonal matrix,
a shift invariant matrix
and not an arbitrary matrix.
So, we only have to compute
n weights and not n squared.
Yeah, so that's the point.
So, that's one
reason for talking
about convolution and circulant
matrices in this course.
I guess I feel another
reason is that everything
to do with the DFT, with
Fourier and Fourier transforms
and Fourier matrices, that's
just stuff you gotta know.
Every time you're dealing
with vectors where shifting
the vectors comes
into it, that's--
Fourier is going to come in.
So, it's just we
should see Fourier.
OK.
So now I'll go back to
this specially nice case
where the matrix loops around.
Where I have this
cyclic convolution.
So, this would be cyclic because
of the looping around stuff.
So, what was the
point of last time?
I started with this
permutation matrix.
And the permutation matrix
has c0 equals 0, c1 equal 1,
and the rest of the c's are 0.
So, it's just the effect
of multiplying by this--
get a box around it here--
the effect of multiplying
by this permutation matrix
is to shift everything and
then bring the last one up
to the top.
So, it's a cyclic shift.
And I guess at the
very end of last time
I was asking about
its eigenvalues
and its eigenvectors, so can
we come to that question?
So, that's the starting
question for everything here.
I guess we've understood
that to get deeper
into a matrix, its
eigenvalues, eigenvectors,
or singular value, singular
vectors, are the way to go.
Actually, what would be the
singular values of that matrix?
Let's just think
about singular values
and then we'll see why
it's eigenvalues we want.
What are the singular values
of a permutation matrix?
They're all 1.
All 1.
That matrix is a
orthogonal matrix,
so the SVD of the matrix
just has the permutation
and then the identity
is there for the sigma.
So, sigma is I for
this for this matrix.
So, the singular values don't--
that's because P transpose
P is the identity matrix.
Any time I have--
that's an orthogonal matrix,
and anytime P transpose P
is the identity,
the singular values
will be the eigenvalues
of the identity.
And they're all just 1's.
The eigenvalues of P, that's
what we want to find, so let's
do that.
OK, eigenvalues
of P. So, one way
is to take P minus lambda I.
That's just the way we teach
in 18.06 and never use again.
So, it puts minus
lambda on the diagonal,
and of course P is
sitting up here.
And then the rest is 0.
OK, so now following
the 18.06 rule,
I should take that
determinant, right?
And set it to 0.
This is one of the very few
occasions we can actually
do it, so allow me to do it.
So, what is the
determinant of this?
Well, there's that
lambda to the fourth,
and I guess I think it's
lambda to the fourth minus 1.
I think that's the
right determinant.
That certainly has property--
so, I would set that to 0,
then I would find that
the eigenvalues for that
will be 1 and minus
1, and I and minus I.
And they're the
fourth roots of 1.
Lambda to the fourth equal 1.
That's our eigenvalue equation.
Lambda to the fourth equal 1
or lambda to the n-th equal 1.
So, what would be the
eigenvalues for the P 8 by 8?
This is the complex
plane, of course.
Real and imaginary.
So, that's got 8 eigenvalues.
P to the eighth power
would be the identity.
And that means that
lambda to the eighth power
is 1 for the eigenvalues.
And what are the 8 solutions?
Every polynomial
equation of degree 8
has got to have 8 solutions.
That's Gauss's fundamental
theorem of algebra.
8 solutions, so what are they?
What are the 8 numbers
whose eighth power gives 1?
You all probably know them.
So, they're 1, of course
the eighth power of 1,
the eighth power of minus 1,
the eighth power of minus I,
and the other guys
are just here.
The roots of 1 are equally
spaced around the circle.
So, Fourier has come in.
You know, Fourier wakes up
when he sees that picture.
Fourier is going to be here and
it'll be in the eigenvectors.
So, you're OK with
the eigenvalues?
The eigenvalues of P will be--
we better give a
name to this number.
Let's see.
I'm going to call that
number w and it will be
e to the 2 pi i over 8, right?
Because the whole angle is
2 pi divided in 8 pieces.
So that's 2 pi i over 8.
2 pi i over N for a matrix of--
for the n by n permutation.
Yeah, so that's number w.
And of course, this
guy is w squared.
This one is w cubed, w fourth,
w fifth, sixth, seventh,
and w to the eighth
is the same as 1.
Right.
The reason I put
those numbers up there
is that they come into
the eigenvectors as well
as the eigenvalues.
They are the eigenvalues,
these 8 numbers.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8 are the
8 eigenvalues of the matrix.
Here's the 4 by 4 case.
The matrix is an
orthogonal matrix.
Oh, what does that tell
us about the eigenvectors?
The eigenvectors of
an orthogonal matrix
are orthogonal just
like symmetric matrices.
So, do you know that
little list of matrices
with orthogonal eigenvectors?
I'm going to call them q.
So qi dotted qj, the
inner product, is 1 or 0.
1 if i equal j, 0 if i is not j.
Orthogonal eigenvectors.
Now, what matrices have
orthogonal eigenvectors?
We're going back
to linear algebra
because this is a
fundamental fact to know,
this family of
wonderful matrices.
Matrices with
orthogonal eigenvectors.
Or tell me one bunch of
matrices that you know
has orthogonal eigenvectors.
STUDENT: Symmetric.
GILBERT STRANG: Symmetric.
And what is special
about the eigenvalues?
They're real.
But there are
other matrices that
have orthogonal
eigenvectors and we really
should know the whole
story about those guys.
They're too important
not to know.
So, what's another
bunch of matrices?
So, these symmetric matrices
have orthogonal eigenvectors
and--
real symmetrics and the
eigenvalues will be real.
Well, what other
kind of matrices
have orthogonal eigenvectors?
But they might be complex
and the eigenvalues
might be complex.
And you can't know Fourier
without saying, OK, I can
deal with this complex number.
OK, so what's another
family of matrices that
has orthogonal eigenvectors?
Yes.
STUDENT: Diagonal matrices.
GILBERT STRANG: Diagonal
for sure, right?
And then we know that we
have the eigenvectors go
into the identity matrix, right.
Yeah, so we know everything
about diagonal ones.
You could say those are
included in symmetric.
Now, let's get some new ones.
What else?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
GILBERT STRANG:
Orthogonal matrices count.
Orthogonal matrices, like
permutations or like rotations
or like reflections.
Orthogonal matrices.
And what's special
about their eigenvalues?
The eigenvalues of
an orthogonal matrix?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
GILBERT STRANG: The
magnitude is 1, exactly.
It has to be 1 because an
orthogonal matrix doesn't
change the length of the vector.
Q times x has the same
length as x for all vectors.
And in particular,
for eigenvectors.
So, if this was an eigenvector,
Q x would equal lambda x.
And now if that equals that,
then lambda has to be 1.
The magnitude of
lambda has to be 1.
Of course.
Complex numbers
are expected here
and that's exactly
what we're seeing here.
All the eigenvalues
of permutations
are very special
orthogonal matrices.
I won't add permutations
separately to the list
but they count.
The fact that this
is on the list
tells us that the eigenvectors
that we're going to find
are orthogonal.
We don't have to
do a separate check
to see that they are
once we compute them.
They have to be.
They're the eigenvectors
of an orthogonal matrix.
Now, I could ask you--
let's keep going with this
and get the whole list here.
Along with symmetric there
is another bunch of guys.
Antisymmetric.
Big deal, but those
are important.
So, symmetric means A transpose
equals A. Diagonal you know.
A transpose equals A inverse
for orthogonal matrices.
Now, I'm going to put in
antisymmetric matrices
where A transpose
is minus A. What
do you think you know
about the eigenvalues
for antisymmetric matrices?
Shall we take a example?
Anti symmetric matrix.
Say 0, 0, 1, and minus 1.
What are the
eigenvalues of that?
Well, if I subtract
lambda from the diagonal
and take the determinant, I get
lambda squared plus 1 equals 0.
So lambda is i or minus i.
That's a rotation matrix.
It's a rotation
through 90 degrees.
So there could not
be a real eigenvalue.
Have you thought about that?
Or a real eigenvector.
If I rotate every vector,
how could a vector
come out a multiple of itself?
How could I have A transpose
times the vector equal lambda
times a vector?
I've rotated it and yet
it's in the same direction.
Well, somehow that's
possible in imaginary space
and not possible in real space.
OK, so here the
lambdas are imaginary.
And now finally,
tell me if you know
the name of the whole
family of matrices that
includes all of those and more.
Of matrices with
orthogonal eigenvectors.
So, what are the
special properties then?
These would be matrices.
Shall I call them M for matrix?
So, it has orthogonal
eigenvectors.
So it's Q times the
diagonal times Q transpose.
I've really written
down somehow--
I haven't written a
name down for them
but that's the way to get them.
I'm allowing any
orthogonal eigenvectors.
So, this is diagonalized.
I've diagonalized the matrix.
And here are any eigenvalues.
So, the final guy on this
list allows any eigenvalues,
any complex numbers.
But the eigenvectors, I
want to be orthogonal.
So that's why I have the Q.
So, how would you
recognize such a matrix
and what is the name for them?
We're going beyond
18.06, because probably I
don't mention the name for these
matrices in 18.06, but I could.
Anybody know it?
A matrix of that form
is a normal matrix.
Normal.
So, that's the total
list, is a normal matrix.
So, normal matrices
look like that.
I have to apologize for whoever
thought up that name, normal.
I mean that's like, OK.
A little more thought,
you could have come up
with something more meaningful
than just, say, normal.
[INAUDIBLE] that's the
absolute opposite of normal.
Almost all matrices
are not normal.
So anyway, but that's
what they're called.
Normal matrices.
And finally, how do you
recognize a normal matrix?
Everybody knows how to
recognize a symmetric matrix
or a diagonal
matrix, and we even
know how to recognize an
orthogonal matrix or skew
or antisymmetric.
But what's the quick
test for a normal matrix?
Well, I'll just tell you that
a normal matrix has M transpose
M equal M M transpose.
I'm talking here
about real matrices
and I really should
move to complex.
But let me just think
of them as real.
Well, the trouble is that
the matrices might be real
but the eigenvectors
are not going to be real
and the eigenvalues are
not going to be real.
So, really I--
I'm sorry to say really again--
I should get out of
the limitation to real.
Yeah.
And how do I get out of
the limitation to real?
What do I change here if M
is a complex matrix instead
of a real matrix?
Then whenever you
transpose it you
should take its
complex conjugate.
So now that that's
the real thing.
That's the normal thing,
that's the right thing.
Yeah, right thing.
Better.
OK, so that's a normal matrix.
And you can check
that if you took
that M and you figured out
M transpose and did that,
it would work.
Because in the
end the Q's cancel
and you just have 2
diagonal matrices there
and that's sort of automatic,
that diagonal matrices commute.
So, a normal matrix is one that
commutes with its transpose.
Commutes with its
transpose or its conjugate
transpose in the complex case.
OK, why did I say all that?
Simply because--
oh, I guess that--
so the permutation
P is orthogonal
so its eigenvectors, which
we're going to write down
in a minute, are orthogonal.
But actually, this matrix
C will be a normal matrix.
I didn't see that
coming as I started
talking about these guys.
Yeah, so that's a normal matrix.
Because circulant
matrices commute.
Any 2 circulant
C1 C2 equals C2 C1.
And now if C2 is
the transpose of--
so, here's a matrix.
Yeah, so these
are matrices here.
Circulants all commute.
It's a little
family of matrices.
When you multiply them
together you get more of them.
You're just staying in
that little circulant
world with n parameters.
And once you know the first row,
you know all the other rows.
So in fact, they all have
the same eigenvectors.
So, now let me be sure we get
the eigenvectors straight.
OK.
OK, eigenvectors of P will
also be eigenvectors of C
because it's a combination
of powers of P.
So once I find the
eigenvectors of P,
I've found the eigenvectors
of any circulant matrix.
And these eigenvectors
are very special,
and that's the
connection to Fourier.
That's why-- we expect
a connection to Fourier
because we have
something periodic.
And that's what Fourier
is entirely about.
OK, so what are
these eigenvectors?
Let's take P to be 4 by 4.
OK, so the eigenvectors are--
so we remember, the
eigenvalues are lambda equal 1,
lambda equal minus
1, lambda equal I,
and lambda equal minus I. We've
got 4 eigenvectors to find
and when we find those,
you'll have the picture.
OK, what's the eigenvector
for lambda equal 1?
STUDENT: 1, 1, 1, 1.
GILBERT STRANG: 1, 1, 1, 1.
So, let me make
it into a vector.
And the eigenvector for
lambda equal minus 1 is?
So, I want this shift
to change every sign.
So I better alternate those
signs so that if I shift it,
the 1 goes to the minus 1.
Minus 1 goes to the 1.
So the eigenvalue is minus 1.
Now, what about the
eigenvalues of i?
Sorry, the eigenvector that
goes with eigenvalue i?
If I start it with 1 and
I do the permutation,
I think I just want i, i
squared, i cubed there.
And I think with this
guy, with minus i,
I think I want the
vector 1, minus i,
minus i squared, minus i cubed.
So without stopping
to check, let's
just see the nice point here.
All the components
of eigenvectors
are in this picture.
Here we've got 8 eigenvectors.
8 eigenvalues, 8 eigenvectors.
The eigenvectors
have 8 components
and every component is
one of these 8 numbers.
The whole thing is constructed
from the same 8 numbers.
The eigenvalues and
the eigenvectors.
And really the
key point is, what
is the matrix of eigenvectors?
So, let's just write that down.
So, the eigenvector matrix
for all circulants of size
N. They all have the same
eigenvectors, including
P. All circulants C of size
N including P of size N.
So, what's the
eigenvector matrix?
What are the eigenvectors?
Well, the first
vector is all 1's.
Just as there.
So, that's an
eigenvector of P, right?
Because if I multiply by P,
I do a shift, a cyclic shift,
and I've got all 1's.
The next eigenvector
is powers of w.
And let me remind
you, everything
is going to be powers of w.
e to the 2 pi i over N.
It's that complex number
that's 1/n of the way around.
So, what happens if
I multiply that by P?
It shift it and it
multiplies by w or 1/w,
which is another eigenvector.
OK, and then the next one in
this list will be going with w
squared.
So it will be w fourth, w to
the sixth, w to the eighth.
Wait a minute, did I get
these lined up all right?
w goes with w squared.
Whoops.
w squared.
Now it's w to the fourth, w
the sixth, w to the eighth,
w to the 10th, w to the
12th, and w to the 14th.
And they keep going.
So that's the eigenvector
with eigenvalue 1.
This will have the eigenvalue--
it's either w or the conjugate,
might be the conjugate, w bar.
And you see this matrix.
So, what would be
the last eigenvector?
It would be w--
so this is 8 by 8.
I'm going to call that the
Fourier matrix of size 8.
And it's the eigenvector matrix.
So Fourier matrix equals
eigenvector matrix.
So, what I'm saying is
that the linear algebra
for these circulants
is fantastic.
They all have the same
eigenvector matrix.
It happens to be the most
important complex matrix
in the world and its
properties are golden.
And it allows the fast
Fourier transform,
which we could write in
matrix language next time.
And all the entries
are powers of w.
All the entries are
on the unit circle
at one of those 8 points.
And the last guy would be w to
the seventh, w to the 14th, w
to the 21st, 28th,
35th, 42nd, and 49th.
So, w to the 49th
would be the last.
7 squared.
It starts out with
w to the 0 times 0.
You see that picture.
w to the 49th.
What is actually w to the 49th?
If w is the eighth root of 1,
so we have w to the eighth,
it's 1 because I'm doing 8 by 8.
What is w to the 49th power?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
GILBERT STRANG: w?
It's the same as w.
OK, because w to the
48th is 1, right?
I take the sixth power of this
and I get that w to the 48th
is 1.
So w to the 49th
is the same as w.
Every column, every entry, in
the matrix is a power of w.
And in fact, that power
is just the column number
times the row number.
Yeah, so those are
the good matrices.
So, that is an
orthogonal matrix.
Well, almost.
It has orthogonal
columns but it doesn't
have orthonormal columns.
What's the length of
that column vector?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
GILBERT STRANG: The
square root of 8, right.
I add up 1 squared 8 times
and I take the square root,
I get to the square root of 8.
So, this is really--
it's the square root of 8
times an orthogonal matrix.
Of course.
The square root of
8 is just a number
to divide out to make the
columns orthonormal instead
of just orthogonal.
But how do I know that
those are orthogonal?
Well, I know they have to be
but I'd like to see it clearly.
Why is that vector
orthogonal to that vector?
First of all, they have to be.
Because the matrix
is a normal matrix.
Normal matrices
have orthogonal--
oh yeah, how do I know
it's a normal matrix?
So, I guess I can do the test.
If I have the permutation
P, I know that P transpose P
equals P P transpose.
The permutations commute.
So, it's a normal matrix.
But I'd like to see
directly why is the dot
product of the first
or the 0-th eigenvector
and the eigenvector equals 0?
Let me take that dot product.
1 times 1 is 1.
1 times w is w.
1 times w squared is w squared.
Up to w to the seventh, I
guess I'm going to finish at,
equals 0.
Well, what's that saying?
Those numbers are these points
in my picture, those 8 points.
So, those are the 8 numbers
that go into that column of--
that eigenvector.
Why do they add to 0?
How do you see that the sum
of those 8 numbers is 0?
STUDENT: There's symmetry.
GILBERT STRANG: Yeah,
the symmetry would do it.
When I add that guy to that guy,
w to the 0, or w to the eighth,
or w to the 0.
Yeah, when I add 1
and minus 1, I get 0.
When I add these guys I get 0.
When I add these--
by pairs.
But what about a 3 by 3?
So, 3 by 3.
This would be e to
the 2 pi i over 3.
And then this would
be w to the 4 pi--
this would be w squared,
e to the 4 pi i over 3.
And I believe that those
3 vectors add to 0.
And therefore they are
orthogonal to the 1,
1, 1 eigenvector because
the dot product will just
want to add those 3 numbers.
So why is that true?
1 plus e the 2 pi i over 3 plus
e to the 4 pi over 3 equals 0.
Last minute of class today, we
can figure out how to do that.
Well, I could get
a formula for--
that sum is 1 and I
could get a closed form
and check that I
get the answer 0.
The quick way to see it is
maybe suppose I multiply by e
to the 2 pi i over 3.
So, I multiply every term, so
that's e to the 2 pi i over 3.
e to the 4 pi i over 3.
And e to the 6 pi i over 3.
OK, what do I learn from this?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
GILBERT STRANG: It's the same
because e to the 6 pi i over 3
is?
STUDENT: 1.
GILBERT STRANG: Is 1.
That's 2 pi i, so that's 1.
So I got the same sum,
1 plus this plus this.
This plus this plus 1.
So I got the same sum when
I multiplied by that number.
And that sum has to be 0.
I can't get the same sum--
I can't multiply by this
and get the same answer
unless I'm multiplying 0.
So that shows me that
when n is odd I also have
those n numbers adding to 0.
OK, those are the basic--
the beautiful picture
of the eigenvalues,
the eigenvectors
being orthogonal.
And then the actual details here
of what those eigenvectors are.
OK, good.
Hope you have a good weekend,
and we've just got a week
and a half left of class.
I may probably have one more
thing to do about Fourier
and then we'll come
back to other topics.
But ask any questions,
topics that you'd like to see
included here.
We're closing out 18.065 while
you guys do the projects.
OK, thank you.